ça fait 15 jours que je l'espère dans
mon t-shirt pour personnes empoisonne
vous êtes beaucoup retiendront et bien
bienvenue dans cette vidéo théorie du
complot quatrième ou cinquième du nom
dans laquelle vous apprendrez que les
avions lâcher les gaz toxiques
le sujet génial parce que je trouvais ça
ridicule presse comme la terre plate et
je me suis documentée à mort et
maintenant je trouve ça moins ridicule
tue pas là pour dire si c'est vrai ou
pas comme d'habitude blabla ici insérer
un discours politiquement correct pour
désamorcer tout ce qui va suivre
je vous connaissez on va en venir au
fait très rapidement avez vous entendu
parler des comme trucks ouais j'ai
travaillé mon accent anglais look bovio
raid
là j'en ai trop fait alors je vous
apprends rien en vous disant que les
avions dans le ciel est ce une traînée
derrière eux ce truc là c'est tout
simplement la condensation de la vapeur
d'eau va émettre le moteur quand il est
en route à haute altitude uniquement
parce qu'il fait froid très froid elles
vous sûr qu'il s'agit bien de traînées
de condensation et non pas d'un produit
que le gouvernement lâche en cash atur
la population j'avoue être secrètement
fans de cette théorie vraiment les a
mais on ce cap déjà commençons par le
début alors cette théorie contrairement
à ce qu'on croit il ya vraiment beaucoup
de gens qui croient beaucoup plus que de
gens qui croient à la terre plate
d'ailleurs la différence c'est qu'à
énormément de gens qui rejoignent le
groupe de la terre société juste pour se
moquer de vraiment alors que là j'ai
regardé c'est essentiellement des gens
qui croient vraiment et qui défendent le
truc en tout cas on allume tous notre
esprit critique pendant cette vidéo
c'est parti on y va on parlait des
traînées derrière les avions pour ces
gens quand je dis ces gens je parle de
ceux qui sont convaincus que les comme
child existe il ya deux types de traîner
derrière les avions il y aller comme tu
as la condensation de la vapeur d'eau
qui sort des moteurs comme j'ai dit au
début de vidéo il y aller comme tu es
comme comme comique holtz comme nichols
qui veut dire chimiques une traînée
chimiques alors n'y a pas de preuves
tangibles ya juste des photos qui
montrent des grosse traînée derrière des
avions et pour ces gens c'est traîner là
c'est pas de la condensation à ce stade
là c'est quelque chose qui lançait
volontairement dans l'air par les avions
en plus de la condensation que l'avion
peut faire certaines personnes ont
remarqué aussi que connaissent des plus
jeunes et qui regardait le ciel il
voyait des avions et voyez pas traîner
l'arrière alors que maintenant
effectivement dès que tu veux un avion
dans le ciel maya une [ __ ] de traîner
derrière lui quoi et plus il est haut
plus à traîner grosse et ces gens il
explique sa part la volonté du
gouvernement de bâle en sait quelque
chose dans l'atmosphère mais dans quel
but pourquoi vous faites ça gouvernement
alors à partir de là il ya plusieurs
théories parce qu'ils ne savent pas
exactement pourquoi ils font ça on va
commencer par les plus tranquilles pour
aller au plus vénère c'est plusieurs
théories dans une seule théorie du
complot chose un génial premièrement il
pense que ce serait peut-être dans le
but de contrôler la météo pour mieux se
défendre c'est un avantage s'il ya une
faillite à un moment où une embrouille
j'ai d'ailleurs appris qu'on était
capable en semences et un nuage de
manière à provoquer la pluie plus
rapidement je ne savais pas mais
apparemment c'est déjà utilisée en chine
pour augmenter les précipitations dans
les zones touchées par la sécheresse en
gros on va envoyer une roquette sur le
nuage
hyper violent dans laquelle il ya entre
autres des cristaux diot dur d'argent
aucune idée des propriétés de ton clamé
en tout cas ça a provoqué une pluie ce
serait aussi utilisé pour empêcher le
brouillard dans les aéroports ou
empêcher des chutes de grosse grêle
pouvant endommager ce cas en dessous
dans les villes ou endommagées même les
gens sachant ça ça paraît donc crédit
que le gouvernement soit capable
d'envoyer des produits chimiques dans
l'air dans le but de contrôler la météo
après je vois pas pourquoi ce serait du
coup un truc secret ne pourrait
totalement nous dira pas de problème
surtout que ça nous arrange de passe
prendre de la graine monumentale sur la
gueule deuxième théorique elle aussi est
plutôt gentil a peut-être que le
gouvernement et bienveillant il
lâcherait un mélange chimique dans le
but de dévier le rayonnement solaire
faut lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et l'appauvrissement de la
couche d'ozone en gros les rayons du
soleil repartirai vers l'espace au lieu
de toucher la couche d'ozone et la terre
ça me paraît un peu gros mais ok on
n'est pas là pour valider ou pas une
théorie on est juste là pour prendre
connaissance de ces théories et
peut-être dire s'il y en a des plus
connus que d'autres après y'a pas
d'alors ya des tas de photos montrant
des intérieurs d'avions avec beaucoup de
bonbonnes qui contiennent des produits
audio [ __ ] cet avion a dû lâcher un
truc dans l'air clos talent on connaît
des incendies sur ton californie à des
avions qui passent au dessus et qui sont
équipés pour lâcher un produit dans
l'air en l'occurrence des produits qui
ont pour but d'éteindre le feu mais il
pourrait utiliser la même technologie
pour lâcher des produits pas dans le but
d'éteindre les feux troisième théorie et
là on rentre dans les théories qui sont
pour moi les plausible si la théorie du
complot ici est vraiment comme tu l je
serai plus pour ces raisons là que pour
des trucs gentils ou alors ils nous
l'auraient dit je pense ce serait
mosanto qui serait derrière ce lâcher
produits chimiques dans l'atmosphère
mosanto qui est une boîte qui a entre
autres fait des pesticides est à
l'origine des ogm
allah vous avez vu sur dans les médias
le débat autour du glyphosate et même si
nous sommes tous aux digues ce produit
n'est pas du tout nocifs pour l'homme il
ya des tas de témoignages de gens qui
ont eu des cancers qui sont morts après
avoir utilisé ce produit là pendant des
années dans leur chambre fc lâcher de
produits chimiques aurait pour but de
détruire les plantations sauf que les
céréales modifiées génétiquement comme
ce que propose mosanto résisterez à
cette tombe et de produits chimiques
dans tous les agriculteurs au sol voyant
leurs plantations pourrir et mourir se
tournerait vers mosanto pour leur
acheter leurs ogm qui eux résisterez
assez tomber
vraiment des [ __ ] de crapule des
voyous dans ce monde doit ouvrir un truc
comme ça me paraît même pas impossible
quoi et maintenant la théorie la plus
connue celle que ces gens croient le
plus et je comprends parce que c'est la
plus violente de tout il lâcherait un
mélange de métaux lourds dans
l'atmosphère plus précisément un mélange
d'aluminium de baryum et de strontium
qui sont des trucs très mauvais pour la
santé et le gouvernement lâcherait ses
cocktails nocives dans l'atmosphère dans
le but d'augmenter les maladies au sol
et donc l'espérance de vie et donc de
combattre la surpopulation avait du coup
c'est pour notre bien
comme tu ailles je trouve qu'il ya des
moyens un peu moins abusé de combat tu
assures population comme par exemple ya
eu en chine quand ils ont réduit le taux
de fertilité et qu'ils ont limité à 1 le
nombre d'enfants possible par couple
alors éthiquement parlant c'est un peu
chaud de faire ça mais en vrai c'est
moins chaud que juste de balancer du gaz
pour tuer les gens et créé des maladies
voilà les quatre possibilités de
pourquoi le gouvernement lâche raid et
comme tu l si culturel il viaggio rappel
c'est pas du tout prouvé alors tout ça
c'est bien beau ça fait rêver mais
maintenant rationalisons un peu tout ça
premièrement si la majorité des avions
était vraiment équipés pour lâcher des
produits chimiques en plein vol ça veut
dire que tous les mecs qui bossent dans
un aéroport les mécanos les pilotes ce
qui m'était bagages en soute qui
entretiennent l'avion tous ces gens là
feraient partie du complot c'est quand
même un peu abusé deuxièmement ces
traînées elles ont lieu quand l'avion
est très très haut dans ciel et donc
avant d'atteindre le sol monga elle se
tape du vent mais pendant des heures
dans quel n'atterrirait pas du tout le
gouvernement veut qu'elles atterrissent
y aurait une trajectoire un peu
aléatoire vu comme elle serait soumise
aux vents et du coup serait pas du tout
les effets escomptés par le gouvernement
puisque ça tombe pas au bon endroit sauf
il est vrai si le but est vraiment
d'affaiblir les gens et de le rendre un
peu te b o quelqu'un on s'en fout de là
où ça tombe tant que ça tombe sur des
gens alors que d'habitude je propose de
regarder quelques vidéos pour conclure
cette vidéo là de manière à voir si les
arguments de ces gens sont tangibles
si ma fille 724 jours avant la retraite
allez tu peux le faire patrick c'est de
la condensation souffle sur ta fenêtre
un soir d'hiver tu vas voir ça mais ce
4h gaulé comme trail salut à flinguer le
cerveau labèque oui américain lui même
il a sniffé du gameplay il est allé au
cul de l'avion il a fait ça soyez des
vidéos de gens qui check dans le ciel
les avions qui ont des traînées normale
et les autres des traînées de comtrade
une très grosse truqués dans le coup l
ariège que tant qu'ouragan à gages qui
t'ont cours ici un autre qui arrive
voilà là il a plein d'avion qui passe
accentue et surtout ça qui est
impressionnant gros à temps mais il mais
qu'il ya une piste d'atterrissage dans
son jardin voilà c'est mathieu ah oui
j'ai oublié de parler de ça apparemment
les comme xiii il laisserait des ti
flamand semblables à des toiles
d'araignées quand ils atterrissent au
sol
le film de champreux nuit n'a aucune
résistance et j'ai complètement
élastique au lieu de prélever des
chemins trails payes tes factures gaulle
a vraiment à une mise en demeure qui est
juste à droite tu peux pas laisser ça
aux montages quoi faut faire un truc
oh [ __ ] attendait là on a un pilote
qui parlent enfin défense féroce et joe
qu'est ce qui nous dit que tu ne fais
pas partie du complot et hussein aux
commandes du contraire
ok mais ouais t'es en train de cacher le
fait que sa balance des comme 13 par le
bout des doigts c'est tout ce qu'on voit
ici joe jackson quelque chose alors tu
dis quoi la baisse aurait du sens
justement parce que du coup tu peux dire
alors que si vous le faites vous êtes
malade
karakama
[Musique]
mais c'est génial qui relie ça aux
pesticides quoi ils montrent le vrai
problème
regardez le jeu laisse juge j'adore jo
il est trop cool j'espère que tu pleures
travaux qu on mènera halo 3 attendait à
elisa bat tours qui intervient attendait
il se fout carrément de nous avec son
titre menteurs ils pensent que nous
sommes les moutons qui ignore qui nous
conduit par la main qu'il est carrément
stupide soit disant pilote l'habit ne
fait pas lemoine n'oublions pas ça
écoute duo j'ai vu clair dans son jeu
tout ce que tu dis c'est des foutaises
aujourd'hui il nous faut un leader il
faut quelqu'un pour changer ce monde
pour prouver que les chemtrails existe
vraiment et les réduire à néant
ah non mais c'est le grand prophète
c'est lui
c'est michel d'allemand il faut avertir
le grand public les amis et si on y
allait en groupe on rentre un orly par
exemple on passe derrière on trouve la
salle de repos des pilotes on voit
lesquels font ce job là et on leur colle
t pas jusqu'à ce qu'il jure de ne plus
recommencer
oh [ __ ] elle est la solution elle est
là bravo messieurs avant les amis on
rigole on rigole mais c'est la fin de la
vidéo n'hésitez pas des mécènes vous a
plus attention à ne pas croire tout ce
que vous lisez sur internet je parle pas
de tous ceux qui partent de comtrade je
parle juste de témoignages un peu bidon
de preuves vraiment fausses comme le
bouton la photo du bouton c'est nul
c'est honteux
quoi qu'il en soit j'adore cette théorie
j'espère l'avoir froisser personne comme
d'habitude et si vous croyez au comme
trail sagem je vous respecte vous avez
sûrement de très bonnes raisons d'y
croire
mais attention à ce que vous lisez vous
êtes jeune logiquement pu vous être
influençable c'est normal je n'étais
aussi énormément pendant un moment et
quand tu grandis que ton esprit critique
grandit aussi tu te rends compte que
certains trucs et tu fais à temps mais
non en fait en tout cas un beau
spectacle à los angeles après cette
vidéo phare au moment là voyez je serai
quasiment déjà revenu mais je vous fais
plein de bisous a très vite ils vont
aller au petit matin c'est 5 à 13 ans
plus tard
annuler comme hystérique ans
[Musique]